ご視聴ありがとうございました
死ぬ
こちらソウズ、平成基地、応答せよ
なんだって
するとソーズはそれ以上は進めないってのか
分かった
それじゃあ天候の回復を待ってヘリを飛ばしてくれ
通信終わり
みんな話は今聞いた通りだ
俺たちはしばらくここから出られねえだか
ああ
迎えのヘリが到着するまでこのまま待機だ
問題が一つ
何だ
我々第一次南極越冬隊は全部で5人
だがヘリに乗れるのは一度に4人だけ
この悪天候の中
ヘリが2回往復できるかどうかは神のみぞ知るんだ
つまり俺たちの中で一人だけ置いてきぼりになるっつうわけか
こいつには勝てるだろうな
まあいくらなんでもこいつには
いいかもう一度言うぞ
勝負は南極ルールのナンバーだけ
一人一回ずつ親をやったらそれで終わりだ
ああ、俺は隊長だから、ヘリには一番先に乗り込む。これ、決定ね。
よし、俺の出親だな。
チー!
まだ五巡目なのに、両面チー?
こいつ、ドラのチュンあんこか。
パッサ!
フラン!タイヤを先転!
一人で暮らす南極の冬は寒いぜ
くそ、俺の親をたった千点で流しやがって
といといにこのハツは綺麗
こっちだ!
おっと、失礼。何のみせんてん?
せいぜい一人でオーロラでも眺めて過ごすんだな。
にゃろー。
借りは返したぜ。
どう?
リーフのみ、せんてん。
おー!三面ちゃんでたまてん!渋い渋い!
ひどいハイパイだー!
それポンだ?
ヤスがツモ上がりすれば、俺は3位でギリギリセーフ。
ヤスはまだいいシャンテンに違いない。必要範囲を泣かせて早く上がらせちまおう。
そら、なぜ?
あんた、出たか?ちゅんのみ1000点だ!
同点だす。
何?ヘリコプターには6人まで乗れるって?
うわぁ、なんだ?それじゃ最初っから1人分の余裕があるんじゃないか?
よかった!心配させて、この!
そうだったな。お前らのことをすっかり忘れてたぜ。
トヨタミ君、いよいよ明後日ね、帰ってくるのは。
そうだ!明後日は豊臣くんの大好きな鴨鍋にしよっと!
ふん、バカバカしい。犬が相手じゃ、結果は目に見えてるぜ。
生意気にぃ!何がポンだよ、この!
実は、この兄弟犬タロとジロは、お互いのテレパシーで欲しい範囲が分かり合えるのであった。
ドラなんか泣かせやがって
まったく犬はしょうがねえな
タロがマンズのチーズに走っているのは見え見えだが
犬なんかに負けてたまるかったんだ
ぼく!
よーし、いいぞ。俺が振り込まない限り、ラッスンは馬場だぜ!
だ、だが、安排がない。
このルールでリーチをかけてくる以上、パーピンのひっかけは十分にあり得る。
スーサのまたげも一番危険だし、ここはスーアンの壁を信じて。
意外と、まんずまちはない!
リーチ、一発、メンホン、一通、羽根は、ギー、ババタインと同じ。
だが、しかしまだ点数はババタインと同じだ。4位が確定したわけじゃない。
う、ウラドラ、パイバー?
豊臣くんのご家族の方ですか
南極隊員の皆さんですね
この旅は
なぜ
お嬢さん
こいつも結構おいしいかもなんですよ
あら、そう?
はい
ラーン、めんたんぴん一発、いいぺいこドラドラ
スカーン
ほんと、息は弱いしよくふりかむし、なかなかいいかもだわ
そうでしょ
じゃあ、もう半端やりましょう
スカーン
そして1年後
織田たちは第二次越冬隊として再び南極へと向かった
シンさん
豊臣は生きているかな
それは分からんな
だがもし生きていたら
もし生きていたら
こ、これは一体どういうこと?
ひどいな
やつは南極の氷になっちまっただ
かもな
何か聞こえる
こっちだ
シェンさんあれ
なんだペンシー
トヨトミ
あの野郎
魚をかけてペンギン相手に麻雀してやがる
それで生き延びてただっぺ!
トヨトミ!
ヤロウ、逃げたの?
つかな、ヤロウ!
ヤロウ、生意気に生きてやがって!
一人寝の諸君
ご自愛のことを
風邪ひじばたやまいたら
超売れっ子漫画家 畑山雅之氏 豪邸訪問
はあ、気持ちよかった
ねえ、豊臣くんも泳がない?
僕はね、泳ぐより泳いでいる君を見ている方が好きなのさ
それにしても豊臣くんにあんな才能があったなんて
自分の月の無さをウルトラズガンなんて漫画にして
あっという間に一千万部ですものね
師匠
お客様がお見えです
誰?
はい
それが昔からのご友人とかいう
けったいな三人でございまして
なんでも
ウルトラズガンのモデルは俺たちだー!
モデル代よこせー!アンダー!アンダー!
などと、訳の分からんこと言うて騒いどりますけれど。
フッ、来たか。
かまわん。追い返せ。
あんたら、師匠は今忙しいよって。またの機会にしてんか?
クソ!俺たちに門前バレーを食わせるつもりか?
野郎、幸せを独占しやがって!
俺にもくんろう、幸せを俺にも分けてくんろうよ、な。
豊臣くんいいの?追い返しちゃって
ふぅ、そんなことより、君にプレゼントだ
え?
うわぁ、素敵ぃ!
ありがと!
んー、ちゅっちゅっちゅ
師匠
豊臣くん嬉しいわ!
好き好き、だーい!
師匠
うわぁー
なんだよ
お客様でございます
またか!早く追い返せ!
けど、ファンの子で、なんと女子大生ですせ!
これも割とグラマーな
アキナちゃん、ちょっと用ができてしまったみたいだ
また今度、ゆっくりね
やや、よく来たね
ああ、初めまして。私、サトミと言います
私、先生の大ファンなんです
僕がかの豊臣秀行です
握手しちゃった
そうだせっかくだから僕の仕事場へ案内しましょうか
嬉しい
お邪魔します
あら
お仕事する机がないわ
僕はね
こうやってお仕事するだよ
大人しくしなって
ランボーはやめて
ほらほらほらほらほら
残高7000万円
無手一行
さすがに通常寿命はよく聞くにゃ
あ、あきなちゃん、こ、これにはわけが!
ケダマロ!
あ、あきなちゃん!
あ、あきなちゃん!ちょっと、あきなちゃん、うわぁ!
こんにちは。ユカリです。エリコです。
君たちは?
サトミの友達です。一緒に来る予定だったんですけど。
やだ、遅かったじゃな。
ごめん。ちょっと電車が遅れちゃった。
ねえねえ、あの人7000万も貯金があるのよ
え、うそ
しかもあの人、麻雀は弱いって評判よ
ねえ、先生、時間あります?
ん?何かね
麻雀しません?
麻雀?
いいけど
けど?
僕はね、もう普通の麻雀はやれない体になっちまってるんだ
それでも構わないかい
あのどんな
僕の麻雀は
振り込んだものはたとえそれが千点のみであれ
服を一枚ずつ脱いでいくという
野球犬麻雀だぜ
面白そう
私がちいちゃだわ頑張らなくちゃ
えっと
はいはいサクサクいくよサクサク
ぐへへへ、なんて素直ないい子たちなんだろう?
はいっぱいもいいし!
げへへへへへへ
さんす、ぴん、ちぃ!
チュン!いらない!
ハッ!
ぽん!
ぐははは
賞賛権なんかいらないものね
ラン!
遥波!
はい脱いで!
いやあ!
うおぉ могут
ラッピー
おやおや、お嬢さん。そんなのを着るんですか?
ラーン!ジュンノミー!ハーイ!脱いで!
嫌だ!また?
キュースソ!
-ラーン!-ソ!
ドヒクメ!タイヤを3色ならずのピンクの目!ハイ脱いで!
もう、そんなてキュースは見送りをね。
エンディング
話が違うじゃない
マージャン強いじゃないこの人
おかしいわね
さあ、追い詰めたぞ。
あった。絶好調だぜ。
この手配なら、ここは普通、ローワンを切ってスーワンを生かした、
二、三、四の三色を狙うところだが。
今の私に点数はいらない。
さあ、ギャンワンサブロキューワマチ、テンパってるんだから出してよ
願うは論法のみ、サブロピマチ単用のみでい
ラッキーなやつ
さあ、最初にそのかわいい胸を見せてくれるのは、ゆかりちゃんか
それともエリコちゃんか?
後もとさとみちゃんか?
先生、先生の番です。
積もっちまった。
これじゃ何にもならねえ。
ここは頭の老腕を切って街を変えていくしかないな。
出た!
ローン、チュン、ホンイツ、ドライチ、万眼!
つかん!
さとみ、あんたは偉いよ、天才!イエーイ!
つかーん!月がなくなった!
こ、国士武装先輩!
どうもー!
くそ、でねえなあ、ぎんに、つ、積もっちまった、くそ、どうして今日はこんなに積もがいいんだ、このまま積も上がりするか、いや、あとあと、ほんのちょっとの努力で、あの、あの魅惑の甘い果実たちが、
しかもホクシは現物以外振り点はなし
ここは素晴らしき男のロマンを求めて
いい番切りだ
ロン ピンプのみ
ロン ピンプインペーカー
ロン ちゃんとちーとい
ズボーン
さあトリプルロンだからズボンもパンツもいっぺんに脱ぐのよ
そうだそうだ
-いや、いや。-よいしょ!
-や、やめて!-よいしょ!次のはんちゃんはこの家をかけてやりましょう!
ず、ずがっ!
こうして、トヨトミは死んだ。
-何なんだよ、お前ら!-よう、トヨトミ、目ぇ覚めたか?
今、バキメしたところだからよ。サクサクやっと、サクサク。
よかった、夢だったんだ
ツモギリ
トヨタミ君?
あなたトヨタミ君じゃない
トヨタミ君
あ、あきなちゃん
アキナちゃんマッチ買ってくれないかい
結局マージャンに負けて彼女たちにあの豪邸まで取られちゃったのね
アキナさん
ケンジさん
その間汚いやつを相手にしたら飽きまへん
貧乏が移りますせ
ケンジお前師匠に向かって
これでクリームパンでも買いなはれ
急ぎまひょパーティーに遅れますよって
ええ
夢がうつつかうつつが夢か
人生まさに古町の夢
おごれるものは久しからず
乗車必衰のことわりをあらわす
つれずれなるままに日暮しすずりに向かいて
春は明けぼる
君は見たか
20年間無敵のジャンキー 桜田文外
もうなんでプロのジャンシーが3人も
一番官の麻雀大会に出なきゃなんないのよ
次回スーパーズガン
腐敗 幻のジャンキー
栄光は他がために
きっと見てね
眠っちゃや
ご視聴ありがとうございました
飛べてくるんだと言うのさ
使うといかねばならぬのだ
リジーとスピードリーツ
ひもちゃかみちゃばじゃん仲間
勝負かけたら情けない
君はアゲマの主席じゃないか
僕の万が一を追うよ
使うと幸せ掴もうぞ
スーパースタート
やるでやるのまんまくところ
ああ 飲んでやるんだ
ここは三面町どころ
行くのかんきゃ
おしむそももせきがはだ
スーモーニーボーマー
ゲングーニーやリュウイテ
買って飲み越すビールがうまい
スカッと
お酒はいどちがけ
ご視聴ありがとうございました